so is it possible to say that one side
is worse than the other in in modern
current political
climate listen I'm a person on the left
I'm not pretending to come here as as
and not knowing that my view is biased
because I'm a person of the left if you
ask Ben Shapiro he'll tell you something
different I think in 2023
sum total the influence of the American
right wing
if the American right wing were to get
everything it wants
it would be a horrifying reality if the
left were to get everything it wants
we'd have to figure out a few things
including exactly how we pay for certain
programs
but they're mostly noble goals and I
believe that they are more supportive of
an individual
self-determining what they want to do in
life and how they want to live and is
more in line with the idea of freedom
and liberty than what the right is
currently proposing that's my view
and of course people will disagree with
me and say no we get to freedom and
liberty the way that the right wants to
do it okay well we can have that
conversation so
I think you've implied in your answer it
was kind of focused on policy
it felt like it was focused on policy
there's other stuff that people worry
about sure um particularly with the left
uh What uh may be termed the woke mind
virus
where have I heard who's using that term
a lot now I'm trying to think I'm not
sure I'm not sure not sure what comes up
uh but the cultural aspect of this that
um
you know if you give a lot of power to
people on the left as you've gave as an
example there would be a lot of kind of
censorship a suppression of speech and a
kind of uh dividing up of a society of
who is allowed to
um
basically a reallocation of resources
not based on Merit but based on some
kind of high ethical Notions of what is
right and only a very small percent of
the population gets to decide what is
what is fair what is right
which is you know uh we already have a
small portion of the population deciding
Fair okay yes but I don't know I don't
know how many different ways I can say
kind of a negative characterization of
uh of folks on the left when we're now
comparing it just as a to play Devil's
Advocate sure so is that is that
something that you worry about so Paul
the setting policies aside uh wokism yes
how big of a problem is it this is a
great conversation so let's two sides of
it okay we have new polling that seems
to suggest so-called wokism is kind of
more popular in the United States than
anti-wokism and I'll tell you what I
mean by that this is the less
interesting part we'll go to the more
interesting part second
um people sometimes what people mean by
wokism is an overreaction
to a perceived
Injustice
that goes beyond what would be fair and
equitable
there was this really interesting poll
in it ask questions like for example do
you believe Society has gone too far not
far enough or just about the right
amount in dealing with issues affecting
the trans community
the woke position which is society
hasn't gone far enough was far more
popular than we've gone too far now the
the right-wing media narrative is we've
gone way too far this is out of control
and there are lots of other similar
answers it's not a huge margin a lot of
these are like 58 to 42 60 to 40. it's
not like 90 to 10 but by a small margin
the so-called woke perspective of we
actually haven't yet done enough to fix
some of these issues is a little bit
more popular so if we went back to
DeSantis this is part of why I think
desantis's anti-woke agenda may just be
a political misstep that's a really
interesting result I wonder how the
questions are
framed
but it's it's still interesting
nevertheless no matter what to hear that
people are majority of people in America
awoke and not in the negative sense of
the word the poll didn't use the term
woke right right this is a critical
thing let's use the word positively the
term has kind of been perverted yes four
years ago when the term was started to
be used I would have said oh yeah woke
just means like I have become aware of
problems that are bigger than any one
person can fix for themselves that
relate to the system I think that's what
and we might disagree on which problems
fall under that category but like it was
kind of benign I think now it just means
like outrageously
left wing maybe even with socialist or
Marxist undertones it's becoming a
pejorative at this but also like bullies
like people sensors yeah but people that
go around calling others racist uh
sometimes oftentimes without any proof
of or justification fair but that's
worse that's that's a few folks on
Twitter you're saying like the polling
is starting to show that like no they're
still
uh most Americans still care about these
issues and want to yeah want to improve
and want to make progress I think that's
the case and they want to do it in a
genuine way that doesn't suppress or
oppress anybody but now let me get to
like to what degree do I think that
actual when it goes too far is a problem
it absolutely exists it we can find
instances of where this exists on the
left
um I've been told many times that as a
Jewish Argentinian immigrant to the
United States
I actually don't qualify as oppressed
enough
because Jews are privileged now in the
U.S and my family had just enough money
to leave Argentina so there's this kind
of like oppression Olympics thing where
I've been told you don't get to comment
for example like a topic in the Latino
Community now is are you familiar with
latinx okay in Spanish there's an
analogous movement
where words by their nature sort of like
have a gender so like the word for
friend is Amigo
but if it's a woman you would say Amiga
so right from there you can tell the
gender that we're talking about and if
it's a mixed group you say amigos it's
the male with an S but it could include
both there's a movement now which wants
to do away with that and put the letter
E in it's a new word okay it's a
gender-neutral word amigues totally new
I don't like that and I don't know
anyone no one in my family uses it and I
think it's kind of like a strange
imposition from someone kind of with
with a solution in search of a problem
I've been told you moved to the U.S long
ago and like your English is good and
like you look white and say like you
don't get to weigh in on that that I
think is an example if I understand
correctly of the type of of thing you're
talking about I'm I'm kind of being
bullied I'm fine I'm surviving fine but
I'm being bullied over it and
disqualified and saying you don't get to
speak on this issue all of those
examples all of that stuff
I am completely against and I tell
people on the left we're actually
hurting our own movement with this stuff
I just don't think it's as big as some
others believe it you don't think it's
an existential threat to uh our
civilization in the west to West no I
don't and and I mean look we've got a
Biden Administration I see Biden as
Center left those who see Biden as
extreme far left this stuff has played
almost no role whatsoever in the first
two plus years of his administration
well there's people that see him far
left as far left
there's people on the right who I mean
Trump says Biden's a Marxist Socialist
Communist
uh I haven't heard that because I don't
think that would stick uh very much I
think at every rally yeah
which I love tell us that you don't
watch these things it's like How Deeply
researched you are in Trump I can only
imagine how good your Trump impression
is at this point it's not very sadly
it's not it's not all right no but and
and I'll say one other thing on on that
you know take trans because Tran just to
talk about it a little bit we haven't
dealt with it much the trans issue has
become huge I believe because the right
is obsessed with it the right is very
much not concerned with gay men anymore
it used to be that gay men is like oh we
have to stop gay men from adopting and
unnatural and pedophiles now it's trans
it's drag shows Etc I do think that
there is a fair question to say how do
we deal with trans women in a very small
short list of sports that's real okay
my view though is I go okay we have all
issues we have issues related to gender
and sexual orientation we have issues
related to Trends within that we have
specifically Sports you can eliminate
from that uh trans men nobody's worried
right about women biological women who
are transmit and then when you say it's
only in certain sports that it matters
hey I'm right there I think it's a
complicated question I don't know how we
deal with it I would ask leagues that
have experience with this already and
whatever the problem I have is
pretending that the the
uh Vanguard of left-wing politics right
now is trying to force trans women into
sports it's like it's just not the big
issue that the right is reacting as if
it were